[Musique]
je suis étudiant en première année en
licence administration internationale
à la base tout dans un lycée français à
l'étranger même promis des bêtes de
trucs ici à la fin y a rien c'est la
merde on n'a même pas de quoi manger
l'arrêt du tout on veut nos droits on va
les encours notre vie normalement
[Musique]
pas du tout
java
top
oui
[Musique]
cette opération ach axima ce hashtag 6
mars c'est quoi c'est cette situation
globale qui va tous vivaient encore de
liberté on sait la faim en nommant
demande afin de se profiler et de ce
couvre-feu
on va pas me faire un café russe il
s'arrête à 18 ans errant prendre matin 6
heures et qui couchent dehors ça
m'étonnerait comme un peu lui toujours
le virus et on attaque ouvrez la fenêtre
pour qu'ils puissent rentrer nous
contaminer là quelque chose qui apporte
quand même dans leurs façons de faire
les gens